Taylor Swift is a phenomenon there is no
denying that right she is known by just
about everyone on the planet certainly
in America I mean her name recognition
competes with folks like Joe Biden and
Donald Trump in terms of how widely
she's known and her popularity is far
greater than either of the people
running for president as Republican and
Democrat so to give you some context Joe
Biden's favorability today is net
negative 15% so a lot more people in
America have an unfavorable view of Joe
Biden than a favorable View and for
Donald Trump that number is
net9 for Taylor Swift it's a positive
35% I honestly don't even know if you
can trust this polling on favorability
views of Taylor Swift but to the extent
you can I'll just site here according to
yugov 54% of Americans have a positive
view of her and only 20% have a negative
view of her